cartoon pig from the uk
has been causing trouble across the pond
american parents have been shocked
to find their kids using british
expressions and even
speaking in british accents oh dear
after their children binged watch
apparently peppa pig over the lockdown
period
he's looked everywhere we can't find the
bits
oh dear i've never seen anything like it
ready daddy
after watching that little pig has your
toddler started calling you
mummy or asking to go to the loo instead
of the bathroom
you might ask why well that's thanks to
peppa pig
kids across the states have apparently
started speaking with a british accent
after binge watching the programme
during lockdown who would have thought
that this little preschool piggy could
be
so influential my daughter has what i
would call the peppa pig
british accent
okay
my five-year-old niece in new york city
had an american accent before the
pandemic now she
has a posh english accent after spending
a year at home watching peppa pig
oh yes my daughter commonly uses words
and phrases like
set nav petrol can i have a go etc
and for christmas i had to put out a
freaking mince pie for father christmas
or as we call him here in the states
santa
american kids watched so much peppa pig
during a pandemic
that they developed british accents and
started regularly using british words
like
holiday instead of vacation confusing
their parents
whatever next god forbid your child
wakes up and makes a nice cup of tea in
the morning
for now the pepper effect is just
dominating young voices with kids
adopting unusual to america vocabulary
and a british accent and this pig's
claim to fame is that she's the second
most
demand cartoon in u.s households just
behind spongebob squarepants
well it's not just parents struggling to
keep up u.s politicians seem to think
that this piggy pandemic is another
british takeover
we fought wars so this wouldn't happen
oh i remember the great battle over the
british tongue
but it seems not everyone thinks that
that's a key event in the history books
we fought wars over english accents i'll
never forget the battle over the q
versus line controversy
that turned into a world war when the
color versus color atrocities were
exposed
so kids wouldn't learn british
pronunciations
i'm pretty sure the revolutionary war
was about something slightly more than
that
so what's so bad with saying you're
pleased and thank yous i think it's
rather lovely but i would wouldn't i
being in the homeland of peppa pig